keiner will der erste sein so was im
spitzensport in der vereins wären es
kaum glauben qualifikations training zum
großen preis von italien in monza
die letzten minuten stehen an alle welt
wartet darauf dass es zum showdown kommt
zum spannenden kampf und die pole
position was passiert die zehn
herrschaften ja zockeln um die strecke
ja wie das und monster das wusste man
vorher
es hatte sich angedeutet es die piste
auf dem man im windschatten sehr sehr
viel gutmachen kann
angeblich zwischen 0,3 bis eine halbe
sekunde das ist enorm viel das macht den
unterschied am ende aus zwischen platz 7
und platz eins und so fern haben sich
die herrschaften zeit gelassen keiner
von ihnen wollte eben ganz vorne fahren
wenn die anderen die möglichkeit bieten
eben im windschatten viel schneller zu
fahren und so fuhr nico hülkenberg im
renault voraus ging dann in den
notausgang hinein angeblich weil er
einen rückspiegel schaute um zu gucken
was die anderen machten die herrschaften
bremste vor der ersten schikane ab und
wollten dem rheinländer wieder in den
vortrag lassen dieses spiel setzte sich
dann quasi eine ganze runde vor die
ingenieure drückten und drängten per
funk ihr müsst schnell erfahren denn sie
wussten ja der hammer fällt nach einer
stunde
wäre da nicht ein bruchteil einer
sekunde vor über die ziellinie kommt
darf keine gezeitete runde mehr fahren
und so ist es passiert nur zwei
schafften das schale clerc im ferrari
und carlos sainz der spanier mclaren der
vorjahr noch eine runde konnte sich
nicht verbessern blieb den sektoren lag
brach die runde ab weil er ja im
vorletzten versuch die bestzeit gefahren
war also poleposition bekommen wir für
alle ist die waren natürlich ein
bisschen aus dem häuschen wie der pole
position
nach dem rennen in spa vor einer woche
also ferrari wieder ganz vorne aber ein
paar andere haus dem roten lager war
nicht so zufrieden vettel klagte
angesäuert aus seinem ferrari heraus
denn er war eben nicht in den genuss des
windschatten gekommen hatte seinerseits
im vorletzten versuch leclerc diese
chance geboten und war dann eben mit
0,15 sekunden rückstand in einer
position aus der heraus er dachte naja
mit windschatten
0,3 sekunden schneller vielleicht eine
halbe sekunde schneller bin ich ganz
weit vorne
vielleicht auf pole-position insofern
ist das bild la klar vor hamilton knapp
vor hamilton
der wiederum knapp vor bottas und dann
vettel mit 0,15 sekunden vielleicht
nicht ganz echt ich hätte gerne einen
echten kampf gesehen um die pole
position weil ich glaube dass mercedes
sehr sehr stark gewesen wäre durchaus
mit chance nehmen auf die pole position
vettel eben auch was sagt das für das
rennen naja lag lag 1 1 wenn ich das so
deuten darf er glaubt ein guter start
und ich bin vorne weg aber mercedes
verweist auf die rennsimulation am
freitag dort waren sie deutlich
schneller
sie glauben dass sie mit den reifen
besser haushalten können so wie das in
belgien war als hamilton knapp verlor
und insofern gehe ich davon aus das ist
ein durchaus spannendes rennen hier in
monza geben wird nur eins wird nicht
kommen obwohl angesagt das ist der regen
so weit aus monster